have i been told many times
during my career um things from
oh you're too young it's not your turn
they're not ready for you um
no one like you has done it before i've
heard all of those things many times
over
the course of my career but i didn't
listen and the person who said all that
was jill biden
[Applause]
welcome back i hope you all enjoyed your
memorial day
or as those who failed history call it
the long weekend
so i had a great time up at the lake i
actually went water skiing with caitlyn
jenner we have tape
amazing strength in those quads but as
expected cat and her new husband spent
the memorial day in typical fashion
[Music]
just an embarrassment and on memorial
day
memorial day all right anyway that
really happened
but how can you tell according to cnn
you can't
last week they reported on a study
claiming that americans exaggerate their
ability
to spot fake news and surprise
republicans are more likely to fall for
fake news
than dems this really just highlights
this news literacy
problem that we have in this country
where people are consuming
misinformation conspiracy theories
things that are just not true
yeah coming from cnn you dope
i got two words for you woolly willy
yeah good call huh russian collusion
anyway if the findings showed the
reverse cnn would never have run the
study
if the story doesn't match their
assumptions it'll vanish faster than
jeffrey epstein's little black book
the study found that overconfident
people are more likely to share false
content taken from
untrustworthy websites so what's that
sound like to you
a cnn anchor if you remember cnn pushed
some of the most false stories
ever from collusion to obstruction to
covington to kavanaugh these guys put
out more fictional content than stephen
king
and now they say you can't tell the
difference between real and fake news
i'd call it gaslighting but only pete
hexs does that after eating a bowl of
beans
[Laughter]
cnn
i just figured maybe stannon is like the
guy on the corner
selling fake rolexes laughing at you for
buying one
and in both cases you know the product
is fake because of where you got it
one guy's just selling it from a tv
studio the other is naked except for a
trench coat standing in front of a times
square peep show
and they're both don lemon but this
this study is brought to you by the
trump era
by destroying legacy media after four
years of trump these guys were more
exposed
than anthony weiner on snapchat at 2am
now we know the emperor has no clothes i
hope that doesn't include brian stelter
sorry for the image so it's not their
fault for pushing fake news it's your
fault they say
which leads me to another stranger study
last year pew reported that
conservatives were far less likely to be
diagnosed with mental health issues
than those who identified as either
liberal or very liberal
the worst sufferers white women aged 18
to 29
who were given a mental health diagnosis
at a rate of 56.3 percent
that's more than double moderates and
conservatives the first thing you learn
from this survey is there's a lot of
mental health issues out there
but you also could have learned that
from being on tinder for a week
but it raises the question do left-wing
ideas cause
mental health issues or do people with
mental health
issues gravitate towards left-wing stuff
another way to ask this is
was pelosi back crazy before she got
into politics
or after let's see what cnn thinks
my sources are telling me that brett
kavanaugh is breaking into people's
homes and stealing their guinea pigs how
can you talk about kavanaugh when we've
got velociraptors and t-rexes all over
the country
misgendering people there is a
widespread transphobia problem and the
velociraptor community that
is true and during pride month
during pride month meanwhile
over at msnbc hello and welcome back to
the 11th hour
i'm your host and original lead singer
of the beach boys brian williams
in today's top story i'll be discussing
the time i was best friends with martin
luther king jr
we met when i was training pterodactyls
how to read sheet music to babies
it was the same month i ascended the
throne of denmark
and invented the color orange that story
and more
after the break
ah save it so why so many liberals
experiencing mental issues
i'm no doctor but i'm not going to let
that stop me
if you're always digesting content from
a conveyor belt of grievances while
thinking there's a bunch of evil people
hell bent on making the world
worse what's that do to your brain well
you get angry you go outside you scream
at cops
you're told the world is nothing but two
groups the oppressed and oppressor
but if you believe that people are
irredeemably bad and there's no justice
then how useful are you if every day
you're constantly monitoring stories of
horrible inequalities applied by your
media source
it's gotta add up and if your ideology
demands all of this behavior
must be eradicated what happens when you
can't do that
you're helpless you're just one person
armed with only a woman's study degree
and a hat that looks like your privates
you become divorced from reality from
your friends and your family
it's now a clash between an impossible
utopian vision and a distorted reality
designed by the media just to make you
mad no wonder so many people are
agitated
especially women who generally care more
about the world than
pigs like me my solution of course is
always going to be skepticism
to step back and see how the media
manipulates you and how that
manipulation affects your mind and your
moods
it's like being in a bad relationship
but you keep coming back for more
but it's not real seriously by
comparison the wizard of oz is
non-fiction
then consider the lost opportunity cost
of wallowing in oppression theater
sometimes you use other people's
problems to avoid your own you display
compassion for refugees but you haven't
spoken to your parents in years
instead of rebuilding your resilience to
overcome life's problems
you fail but at least it's not your
fault it's those damn sweat shops in sri
lanka
it's prison lunches full of gluten it's
anywhere but here
it's anyone but you of course mental
issues exist
independent of the media i have been
insane for decades
and i could be getting worse but the
media has no compassion for your current
state and they use it to their advantage
legacy media needs vulnerable people to
watch their rage creating click bait
but if you brought that up to cnn they
call it fake
[Applause]
welcome news guest
her last name's italian for free
breadsticks with dinner
outnumbered co-host emily compagno
[Applause]
[Music]
he's so handsome even gitmo detainees
we're thrilled to see him
fox and friends weekend co-host
[Applause]
she has a degree in english but always
majors in drama
fox news contributor captain
and he never loses a fight unless it's
with a ceiling fan
my massive sidekick in hosted an upset
on fox nation
hi russ
emily how you doing everything good yes
how's outnumbered working out there
seems to be doing really well despite
you
yeah you you told me what the ratings
spiked yesterday when i wasn't on air
that way
the ratings are high when you're not
there and low and you're there
but let's not get into that now we're
talking about my show
um what is it what what is your take on
this
mental illness it's not mental illness
it's more like mental issues by the way
i do believe they have a low bar for
that
it's like i ca i think i qualify for
that because like i have
oh would you hear that one me
nope you're right you must be hearing
things again no i was like where that
was like a whistle that came out of
nowhere huh what do you think emily
well it makes a little bit of sense
because you had to be diagnosed so it
seems like it makes sense that that
group in particular enjoys all of their
time in psychiatrist offices but
the best part to me was the
condescending delivery of the study
where it was like oh of course because
progressivism
demands equality to such an
unsustainable degree like
essentially saying that yes depression
and anxiety thrive
in environments where you're just
carrying so much right about every
minute
issue on the planet and you can't hope
to rectify it to your point in the intro
which is fine because while everyone
else in that demographic are worrying
themselves to death over which proper
pronoun to address the waiter by i will
be sitting over here
with low blood pressure enjoying my beer
there you are that's why i get depressed
because i care too much
that's the gist well i think that
something else that's huge about it is
at least
like these days liberals really value
victimhood
right it's it's how you get power right
is
intersectionally you have things are the
hardest for you and they undervalue
strength
and individual responsibility and
throughout my life i've i have add adhd
i have anxiety i have depression but i'm
also
somebody who never wants to be defined
by things i've struggled with or defined
by bad things that have happened to me
and try to focus on healing and also a
big part of that for me has been humor
something else to the left doesn't like
making jokes about things
that are potentially tough or dark they
actually crusade against that as a
concept so i think that that's probably
has a lot to do with it too
and there's nothing wrong with some time
in a psychiatrist's office either emily
i will tell you that
you know pete uh if anybody maybe
outside tyrus
who deserves to be heavily stressed out
you have like 37 kids
so it's like i mean the idea that like
that has got to be the
i don't even understand how you live
your life uh
but uh it's actually the only thing that
stresses me out
yes is kids right um by the way they're
filthy animals
they really are not yours just in
general mine are filthy animals
they all are uh they are
[Laughter]
you talk about beans yes they don't go
well with my kids either
uh it must be exhausting to keep score
as for for as long as the left does and
if you're a
young person female male even even uh by
the way
liberal male males had more instances of
mental issues than
conservative females i mean this is not
just a gender thing this is a political
ideology thing right if you're running
around
with your white guilt constantly trying
to address every grievance
and perfect mankind in real time
it how could it not say that
it's contagious that's a mind virus and
you're inflicting everyone else around
you with it and no one wants to be
around
you and then you wonder why doesn't
anybody want to be around me when i'm
judging them all the time how dare they
uh it's it it affects every part of
their life and so i just
i don't know the utopia they envision is
not possible you know what we had a
pastor on our show last weekend he said
what we need is more radical uh grace
theory not radical race theory there's
no forgiveness
there's no actual understanding there's
something bigger than yourself that
we're all fallen we all need help
and if you don't have that
maybe we've all fallen in we can't get
it we're all falling we need a religious
life alert it's fantastic we need like a
little really yes it's
but no you also need the real one you do
you do need the real one too might need
it too wait so i have a theory tyrus
would you like to hear my theorists oh
with i with open arms
you are going to love the this theory is
so mind-blowing that when i wrote it
down i put it on the way let me know
let me get let me get my card face go so
i realized
i realized on memorial day and on
christmas vacation
and thanksgiving there's no news
so the the new mind blown no the news
can turn it
off when they want to because the
executives and the people in charge
are on vacation so suddenly there's no
news do you ever notice this like
on new year's day no news during the
christmas week
no news so it's it they actually create
man the stuff
they manufacture and create the stuff
that we are supposed to get upset about
that's my theory i almost burst a blood
vessel there
i'm actually a little light-headed yeah
you know i'm i'm proud of you and
i think jim acosta would have an issue
with that because his new show's on the
weekends
um i think we're
huh weekend
but it's mid-afternoon yeah when
everyone else is about their day
i guess you know i always the first
thing i do get up is where the whole ph
in the morning get me ready
but i think we're i think we have a lot
of people who like to self-diagnose
yeah uh that's for one and anyone who
you have an argument with will quickly
especially liberal will come up with so
well i have attention to that no you
just don't listen
we see it a lot with the news nowadays
where cnn is getting it
back at him because they talk about
what's fake news yeah now it's coming
back to him
again because i'm a little obsessed with
jim acosta after the trump
i worry about him the the new thing is
now they've discovered that
the wuhan yeah lou might have come from
a lab
yeah new information so we had an expert
from
uh intelligence yeah and he said
yeah it's no new news we were telling
you that but every time we tried to tell
you said we were racist
yeah he's like i don't i don't believe
that to be true he's like no of 100
every time we told you the truth about
where it was coming from it was either
coming from
a wet market or it was coming from their
lab which russia had been complaining
about
and he literally wouldn't listen to him
and then he came back with the best he
come on we didn't cover that on our
website
yes game set match but the point is is
that
we see all these groups when they get it
when it comes back around on them they
don't have
emperor trump to blame it on yeah then
it's all the fake news was not coming
from
where they said it is coming from them
so of course all the if no one agrees
with you of course they're dumb of
course
we're dumb we can't we can't understand
because we don't buy their bull
yeah all right on that note hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else